Ron DeSantis has reportedly told Piers
Morgan in an interview to be released
Thursday that he has what it takes to
beat Joe Biden and no matter what you
think about Rhonda Santos
I think just about everyone has to admit
that he is right
since pretty much anything can beat
Biden these days from bicycles to
staircases to multi-syllabic words as
the president showed us yesterday during
a speech in honor of national poetry day
Richard Blanco returned to a poem he
wrote from the second on inaugural of
rock in me a poem one today says and
always one moon like a silent drum
tapping at every rooftop and every
window on every in of every County
Country let me start this over again
I'm getting so intimidated by you being
here
and always one moon like a silent drum
tapping on every rooftop and every
window of one country County County all
of us facing the Stars hope a new
constellation waiting for us to map it
waiting for us to name it together
if the country
is waiting for Joe Biden to name it
and America is in even worse shape than
I thought that it was but Rhonda santis
is not waiting he reportedly told Pierce
Morgan if I were to run I'm running
against Biden like we Trump and I are
competing for the Republican potentially
I get that but ultimately you know the
guy I'm going to focus on is Biden
because I think he's failed the country
I think the country wants a change I
think they want a fresh start and a new
Direction and so we'll be very vocal
about that
that's what the Santa said verbatim he's
running
and he has to run desantis's final term
as Governor is up in 2026 two years
before the next election after which he
will quite likely be yesterday's news
there is no waiting until 2028 if
DeSantis passes it up now like Chris
Christie did in 2012 it is never coming
back
DeSantis is lagging Trump but he's
within Striking Distance and perhaps
even more important should he beat Trump
and secure the nomination he will almost
certainly be running against a Democrat
who can no longer reliably speak or even
read
this may or may not be Ron desantis's
moment but if he is ever going to have a
moment it's now I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we've got so
much coming up
as part of our national identity crisis
that we're all going through there is a
man who positively lost it in a fast
food restaurant because someone
misgendered him allegedly We Will We
Will delve
into the depths of the madness
first though I want to delve into the
depths of the political Madness that
we've got President Biden couldn't get
through the poem the poem poem one Biden
zero Biden also could not pronounce the
name of a new monument that he is
inaugurating I'm proud to use my
Authority Under the Antiquities act to
establish the and I I want you to know
it's a big deal The
Havana may I I'm having trouble thank
you
I got it
all right this is a really and I want
you to know it's a really big deal the
thing that we're doing that I'm just
reading about now we're inaugurating
we're naming this mountain this new
National Monument as uh
uh what he was trying to say is the Avi
qua AME
which is the Mojave name for Spirit
Mountain in southern Nevada this site
apparently is sacred to tribes including
the Peyote and the chemawei and it
provides a habitat for a bunch of
different species
I have nothing against the Peyote I've
got nothing against the Gemma wavy I've
got nothing against the Mojave or any of
the other Indian tribes in America
this trend though
of naming monuments and National places
for veneration after
cultures other than our own is very
troubling because it represents is a
loss of confidence in our own culture a
loss of affection for our own culture
and embracing of this
Preposterous premise that America is
evil our civilization is evil we stole
the land we killed all people we're the
worst people that have ever walked the
Earth and so we need to we need to
negate our culture we need to concede
our culture and we need to just Embrace
every other culture under the sun
this is not how the Mojave would operate
this is not how the Peyote would operate
this is not how the chema wavy would
operate this is why I always think it's
so Preposterous when you see people
write in their email signatures now
liberals will do this they'll say
sincerely John
P.S I hereby acknowledge that I am on
occupied Land from the hamahuki peoples
that lived here 500 years ago and
whatever because the question that you
always have to ask is okay this land was
previously occupied by the hamahuki
peoples well who did the Hama huki
peoples take it from this is what I've
never understood about giving the land
back to the Indians who are you going to
give it back to
are we going to live give parts of the
Southwest United States back to the
Comanche
or are we going to give it back to the
Apache from whom the Comanche took the
land or are we going to give it back to
whichever native American group the
Apache took the land from this is what's
so crazy about about Mount Rushmore
we're told that Mount Rushmore is a
terrible desecration of land that was
terribly sacred to the I think it's the
Lakota is who claims that they had that
land but the Lakota had taken that land
as recently as 1776.
what about the people that they took the
land from
this is a big problem and it's it's now
infecting all of our national monuments
not just naming mountains after a native
tribe think about even the Martin Luther
King monument that was established a few
years ago
not saying it's a problem intrinsically
with Martin Luther King or anything like
that but the but the point of the
monument is that it's an unfinished
Monument that that Martin Luther King is
emerging out of this Monument it's
unfinished because America is unfinished
because it's still a rotten evil place
so you're not even celebrating anything
it's it's a monument to resentment it's
not even a monument to Martin Luther
King it's a monument to resentment it's
a monument to progressivism it's a
monument to to detract from American
history and the American story and even
the American present that's the point of
that Monument
it's a monument that represents a loss
of faith in the country
and of us as a people compare that to
Mount Rushmore what's Mount Rushmore we
go to a mountain that nobody was really
using and we go blow up parts of it and
carve our founding fathers and Teddy
Roosevelt on the face of the mountain
that's cool that represents a country
that believes in itself and that is
growing but we're depressed now we don't
believe in our own culture our culture
is depressing because our modern
religion is depressing
the weird new kooky religions that we've
taken on
the weird
albigensian gender religion that we've
taken on
the idea that our body and soul are in
opposition to one another the weird
environmental religion we've taken on
which which suggests that we all have to
give up
our our most cherished goods and
sacrifice them to Mother Gaia and if we
just stop producing and if we just stop
procreating and if we just stop living
Our Lives then Mother Earth will be
happy and will save the planet from
imminent destruction that is probably
the most prominent fake religion that is
animating liberal policies
and who is the prophetess of that
religion who is The High Priestess of
that religion
who is the secular saint of that
religion you know who it is it's Saint
Greta of the of the Blessed sailboat now
for many many years now as I have called
her Saint Greta of the Blessed sailboat
for many many years now as I've pointed
out that global warming constitutes less
a scientific observation about the world
and much more a fake false religion
people have said that's crazy Michael
that's awful you're wrong you're an
idiot you're ignorant you don't know the
science okay well
you know I hate to say I told you so we
just got a little evidence for my theory
which is that the University of Helsinki
has decided that it will confer an
honorary doctorate on Greta Saint Greta
tuna burger now are they going to give
her a doctorate in geology
are they going to give her a doctorate
in climatology whatever that is are they
going to give her a doctorate in
meteorology are they going to give her a
doctorate even in biology no
they're going to give her a doctorate in
theology because she is a religious
figure for the false religion of
environmentalism that will happen on
June 9th 2023
I have never been happier to see
somebody receive an honorary doctorate
because this honorary doctorate proves
that everything that I and everything
that you have been saying about
environmentalism and syncreta in
particular
has been true has been true that's what
this is about it's about a new religion
to get rid of our old religion
Christianity this is a new weird secular
liberal religion to animate and to
motivate all of the social upheaval that
they have been trying to undertake and
that they have largely successfully
undertaken speaking of children there's
a great new law in Texas which we'll get
to in one second I will talk to you
about it in one second but first when
you want to talk to each other you got
to check out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles do
not fall for the free phone deals from
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile it is just
another trick it's a ruse to lock you
into a long-term contract that will cost
you a fortune every month instead get a
brand new iPhone 12 from Pure Talk for
just 12 dollars a month no contract no
interest you can cancel or leave at any
time if your talk uses the same
Nationwide networks as major carriers so
you will get the same reliable coverage
you're used to 2 with a range of
affordable plans to choose from you can
find the perfect option for your needs
get unlimited talk text plenty of data
for just thirty dollars a month switch
over to Pure Talk in as little as 10
minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number there are us-based
customer service team frankly is enough
to make the switch completely worthwhile
and they make the switch very easy if
your talk is so sure you're gonna love
the service they're backing it up with a
100 money back guarantee go to
puretalk.com enter promo code and I'll
save 50 off your first month
puretalk.com promo code knows Pure Talk
is simply smarter Wireless
great new law coming out of Texas this
is called the Texas Millstone Act
the millstone Act
wonderfully named would prohibit gender
mutilation procedures for people under
the age of 26.
the Texas scorecard says as more people
have been taken advantage of by greedy
Physicians
the Texas Millstone act would help
protect innocent people from these life
altering procedures
love it it's a great idea
obviously the the transgender Butchery
should be banned for
people under 26 without question
but it's really just a good start
because the
gender reassignment Butchery should be
banned for everybody
for a number of reasons one you know I
don't really trust social science but in
as much as we can rely on social science
uh the largest data set on satisfaction
post-gender reassignment surgery shows
it does not improve mental health
outcomes and on at least one score on
the score of anxiety it would appear to
have made those underlying conditions
worse so from a social scientific
perspective it doesn't work from an
anthropological perspective it's absurd
because men cannot really be women and
women cannot really be men that puts
forward a false human nature at that
that does not fall in line with reality
uh from a political perspective and the
perspective of culture and tradition
it's it's obviously awful because the
moment that you allow one deluded person
to present himself as a woman in public
and demand all the rights and privileges
of women then you've abolished women's
bathrooms and you've abolished same-sex
schools and you have abolished girls
sports teams and you've abolished every
special right and space that women have
the minute the minute you allow one
person of any age
to pretend to be the opposite sex in
public life
all of that's over for women they lose
all of it they can no longer expect to
have any space or right in public that
is exclusive to them and not for men
and it's called the millstone act
because of the the verse from the gospel
in which Christ says whoever causes one
of these little ones who believes in me
to sin it would be better for him to
have a great Millstone fastened around
his neck now this verse is often invoked
to to describe direct child abuse
who as if it said whoever harms one of
these little ones it's often invoked
when it comes to abortion it's often
invoked when it comes to the transgender
surgeries or any other kind of child
abuse but the the verse is not actually
about direct child abuse the verse is
about scandal
it's sometimes translated as whoever
causes one of these little ones to
stumble
the Dua Reems translation says he that
shall scandalize one of these little
ones that believes in me it would be
better for him for a millstone to be
hanged around his neck it's about
scandal
and
so if it's about Scandal then you have
to ban the surgery for everybody
because what is scandalous is not when
you directly go in and trans a kid what
is scandalous is When anybody is
permitted to indulge this falsehood in
public that scandalizes the child that's
a stumbling block for the child on his
way to maturity and education and
understanding reality
so it's a good start but you've got to
take it to its logical conclusion even
The Logical conclusion of the name the
millstone act right it's about Scandal
and we have the right to take action
against Scandal we always have in
America we always have in every society
in the history of the world
we have the right to public standards
and norms
to protect the children certainly but to
protect everybody we have a we have a
right to stand up against obscenity this
is the point of my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
which is available now
conservatives need to get a lot more
comfortable
speaking in explicitly religious terms
for one
it works
okay it it works and the libs know this
and the libs speak in religious terms
conservatives got a wrong idea sometime
after the 90s conservatives got a wrong
idea that the religious right is
ineffective and we need to stop
thumping our Bibles and speaking in
religious terms let's just talk about
taxes or whatever no
the the issues on which conservatives
have spoken in explicitly moral and
religious terms they're the only issues
we've won on
there are two issues conservatives have
one on in recent decades and and as far
as I can tell only to
abortion and guns the Second Amendment
and in both of those cases we speak in
explicitly religious terms obviously an
abortion the right to life given to us
by God and even on the right to guns
through the Second Amendment because
that derives from a right to
self-defense which is evident from the
natural law we have a right to preserve
our own lives and to defend ourselves
those are the issues on all the other
issues where we've rejected the
religious language we've completely lost
on marriage on immigration on foreign
policy on the way the economy works on
everything okay so we need to get a lot
more comfortable with that the libs do
it that's why one of their most popular
public figures Saint Greta thunberg is
about to be given a doctorate in
theology
and it's resonating it's resonating not
just with the right and not just with
the far left it's resonating with people
in the middle it's resonating even with
center-left people Tulsi gabbard just
went on TV to explain what drove her
away from the Democrat Party and it
wasn't just foreign policy and it wasn't
just the corruption of the clintons it
was it was the central issue you see
this erosion of this spiritual
Foundation of our country uh as a direct
consequence of those who are trying to
erase God from from just about every
facet of our public lives this is one of
the main reasons why I chose to leave
the Democratic party because I saw
increasingly how not only were they
trying to erase God from or any mention
of God or uh you know attacking people
of Faith attacking people of
spirituality especially Christians you
see these attacks and you see the
consequences in the direction
unfortunately that much of our our
country is headed in and the Damage it's
causing to families to children to our
communities
um to to our policy makers many of whom
think that they are God and are trying
to control Us in every possible way
exactly I mean that that's been the
error in human society going back to the
fall going back to the Garden of Eden ye
shall be his Gods it's the error the
ex-communist Whitaker Chambers pointed
out that motivates communism that we
shall be as gods and it motivates
leftism more broadly that we're going to
control the whole world
if if we don't
if we don't like the circumstances of
reality we're going to deny them
we're going to do everything we can to
change them even down to our own
identity we will liberate ourselves not
just from the constraints of our natural
environment we will liberate ourselves
from our very own identities if you're a
man and you don't like that you're a man
you can change your name you can refer
to your your true name as a dead name
it's a sort of ritual suicide of your of
your identity you will take on a new
identity you'll change your body you'll
be a completely different person by
killing the person that you actually are
calling that an old dead person you will
liberate yourself even from that
we shall be as Gods exactly what Tulsi
gabbard is saying
and that is a
that is an unappealing religious vision
okay the conservative religious vision
is a lot better hey be grateful give
thanks to God
except reality accept who you are get to
know the Creator who made you in His
image much much better way better than
the libs religious Vision at this point
in as much as they're speaking
explicitly religious terms is basically
as Tulsi gabbard implies give us all the
power and do some weird sex stuff this
was what John Kirby the national uh
Security Council spokesman
just said at the white house the other
day he said that LGBT
LMNOP ideology is now a a key aspect of
American foreign policy
President Biden has been nothing but
consistent about his uh belief
foundational belief in human rights and
lgbtq plus rights are human rights and
we again back to the earlier question
we're never going to shy away be bashful
about speaking up for those rights and
for uh for individuals to live as they
deem fit as they want to live and that's
something that's a core part of our
foreign policy and it will remain so
that's a core part of our foreign policy
transgenderism is a core part of our
foreign policy
then call me an isolationist I guess
I've I've never considered myself an
isolationist I think that great Nations
and Empires need to be involved around
the world that's just a fact of politics
and might not be a happy fact but it is
what it is and so we have a
responsibility and we have
a privilege in some ways to throw our
weight around in the world but what is
our weight
if throwing our weight around in the
world and maintaining a world order
meant truth justice in the American way
great
if throwing our weight around in the
world meant what it traditionally has in
our civilization which is Christendom a
Christian civilization
great that's that's what it meant until
60 70 years ago even more recently
probably
but if throwing our weight around in the
world if spreading our values if
American hegemony means imposing
transgender absurdity
on every Other Nation around the world
I'm out bring the troops home baby get
rid of the bases and a lot of other
Americans feel this way this is why we
ended up pulling out of Afghanistan this
is why there were so many Americans who
were skeptical of intervention around
the world right now
is they say okay I I'm if we're going to
raise the American flag all over the
place whether it's some country in the
Middle East or whether it's on the moon
that's one thing but what if we're not
raising the American flag if we're
raising the rainbow flag if the rainbow
flag is now supposed to represent me I'm
out because that doesn't represent me
and whatever political body that Flag
represents that is unrecognizable to me
you want to talk about a national
identity crisis I do not identify with
that symbol
so what is our country about well you
want to find out you got to check out
prageru many Americans have lost faith
in the government media and schools the
good news is that there is something
that you can do to help get the country
back on track
prageru prageru is an educational
non-profit that is fighting to save the
future of America daily wire and Prager
you work very very closely I host a show
at prageru I've done lots of five minute
videos at prageru Jeremy was involved
with prageru from the very very
beginning it's just been wonderful to
see Prager you grow right now it has
watched five million times a day prageru
videos spread messages of Liberty
economic freedom and the values that
made our country great Jewish values
Christian values for the Next Generation
there truly is hope for America but
prageru needs your help go to
prageru.com make a tax deductible
donation whatever you give right now
will be matched and have triple the
impact donate ten dollars
it goes up to thirty dollars you have
fifty dollars it becomes a hundred fifty
dollars you get the idea go to
prageru.com to make a tax deductible
donation whatever you give will be
tripled my favorite comment yesterday is
from Joe woznowski who says Michael
does your contract with DW have a
built-in microphone replacement Clause
to hedge against your Italian speaking
habits
forget about it forget about it I know I
know that's really that's too bad I'm
gonna don't tell Jeremy about that these
microphones are very very
expensive
best vegan muster with foreign policy
these days
is
to ban Tick Tock the the best well the
the Pentagon is out there they want to
to treat teach transgenderism to little
Afghani boys or I don't know what they
want to do
I think the best the best option that
they have offered is to ban Tick Tock
for which the CEO of tick tock has now
flown to the United States He is
lobbying lawmakers and he's directly
appealing to the American people to get
their lawmakers to allow Tick Tock to
remain in this country here's his
argument hi everyone it's Joe here I'm
the CEO of tick tock I'm here in
Washington DC today and uh I have some
news and updates to share with everyone
here today I'm super excited to announce
that more than 150 million Americans on
Tick Tock yeah that's the US coming to
tick tock to connect
to create to share to learn or just to
have some fun this includes 5 million
businesses that use tick tock to reach
the customers and the majority of these
a small and medium businesses now these
numbers are amazing and I'm so thankful
to all of you and the 7 000 Tick Tock
employees in the US who are helping us
build this incredible community in
America and around the world now this
comes at a pivotal moment for us some
politicians have started talking about
banning Tech talk now this could take
Tick Tock away from all 150 million of
you I'll be testifying about Congress
later this week to share all that we're
doing to protect Americans using the app
and deliver on our mission to inspire
creativity and to bring joy and don't
threaten me with a good time take away
Tick Tock from 150 million Americans I
think a lot of people can get behind
this because we think wow more than half
the country is hooked on this stupid
Doom scrolling app that doesn't add
anything to our lives and only only
destroys our brains and our memories and
opens us up to all sorts of propaganda
and has back doors to the Chinese
Communist party yeah no thanks
a lot of people think that when you add
on to that the the
amount of time that Tick-Tock users
spend on the app
the average Twitter user depends on
which survey you're looking at the
average Twitter user spends something
like two to six minutes a day on the app
some of us spend a lot more time on the
app but but that's the average Twitter
user the average Tick Tock user spends
something like 56 minutes a day on the
app it's not even close it's so many
multiples higher or order of magnitude
higher and then some
so yeah this this represents a a threat
to the American mind
but then my question is okay we're going
to ban tick tock
what about Facebook Twitter and Google
not saying we ban all those things but I
am wondering hold on why are we so
worried about tick tock
well we're worried about Tick Tock
because it's a Chinese company okay
did was it tick tock that de-platformed
the duly elected sitting president of
the United States
was it tick tock that interfered in the
2020 presidential election and
suppressed a news story that was
damaging to Joe Biden and suppressed it
at every single level including private
messages was it tick tock that did that
I don't think it was Tick-Tock as I as I
recall it was Twitter
and Facebook and Google
tick tock's got a bunch of problems if
the lawmakers want to ban it fine
whatever
but actually the people who benefit from
Tick Tock being banned
are Facebook and Twitter
and Google
the the very companies
that have taken so much of our political
power in so many of our rights away that
have acted in a way to dominate the
Public Square which is the political
order in a republic
in which brazenly de-platformed
conservatives and censored conservative
news stories and censored the duly
elected sitting conservative president
of the United States I've heard enough
about Tick Tock do whatever you want
with tick tock
what about those other guys
they're my main concern
and in as much as Banning Tick Tock
helps Facebook and Google and Twitter
Twitter now is owned by Elon so I give
it more slack but in as much as Banning
tick tock
just helps American big tech companies
which pose one of the biggest threats to
conservative political power into our
whole political order in the United
States
and I'm not for it
in as much as it helps those big tech
companies here in Silicon Valley I would
prefer that Tick Tock remain available
just to give those guys a little bit of
competition
because the next time that they move to
censor Trump or whoever the next
Republican nominee is maybe maybe that
Republican nominee will be able to find
a home on Tick Tock they seem to be
playing much more fairly with American
conservatives than than the allegedly
American businesses over in Silicon
Valley are
now social media I think is fueling a
lot of of the insanity around our
culture this is one of the big drivers
I'm convinced of the identity Insanity
you know I talked to a d transitioner
Helena kirschner some time ago and she
said one of the the big factors that got
her down the transgender Rabbit Hole was
social media that he would she would
sequester herself in her room for hours
and hours and days on end and she would
be on Tumblr I think was was the social
media platform that really got her into
it but all these different social media
sites should be divorced from The Real
World
she'd be living in virtual reality
online where the body doesn't really
matter and they would fuel her different
anxieties and they convinced her that
she was really a man and then she came
to regret this this delusion and then
she she has attempted to do Transition
mostly successfully so far social media
is fueling a lot of that
insanity and we're seeing it spill out
beyond the digital world we're seeing it
now in fast food restaurants
all the time
look what's your name Alex yeah your
name's Alex and I'm gonna be talking
your manager this guy called me sir are
you gonna tell me everything everywhere
I go I get called Sir why would you call
a chick
why would you call no stop trying to
cosplay trans people and tell us that
we're why would you call me sir
I heard you stop gaslighting trans
people
okay wait what
did you call me sir again what was that
you said good night sir
Alex I'm gonna be talking how many times
have you seen this video you okay
remember there's the ones that hulking
dude goes into a bodega New York for
instance
remember it's ma'am
what the trans people this is
discrimination no this is discrimination
I'm done with it
who behaves like this who be forget the
gender identity problems for a second
who behaves like this ever
I go out in public occasionally someone
will slight me on occasion you know most
people love me but on occasion someone
will say a nasty comment or insult me or
be rude sometimes even at a fast food
joint
and you know what I do I do the same
thing that you do that every normal
person does say ah okay yeah whatever
buddy okay fine whatever you take your
hamburger and you leave
the kind of people who behave this way
are
I'm probably not allowed to say it on
YouTube so believe me if you have to
whatever
[Music]
it's not just these random weirdos who
throw Hissy Fits at fast food
restaurants this is even prominent
people who are behaving in a way that is
hysterical in the face of reality
there's an actor Billy Porter not sure
that I've ever seen him in anything but
I do see him pop up on talk shows and in
commercials and things like that Billy
Porter was just on The View whining and
screaming and carrying on about Ron
DeSantis
everything is about power and you could
always trace it back to the money you
say that all the time
it's follow the money follow the power
power at any cost it's very hypocritical
you know the the leading cause of death
in children are guns yes yeah yeah
they're guns yeah I know it's the
morning and I'm not supposed to be
screaming but they're guns yeah
not a drag queen no leave us alone
you know and it just it's a distraction
it's a distraction on purpose
here he goes on and and he just says a
lot of things that
sound like they're an argument but
they're not which Libs do a lot they're
these kind of non-sectors and it's
hypocrisy and there are distractions and
you want to talk about let's talk about
let's talk about corporate taxes okay
let's talk about the Second Amendment
all right let's talk about the the 12th
Amendment okay and you just think well
what are we what are you saying about
any of those things nothing really guns
I can't even do it I can't even do the
Billy Porter impression what is he
talking about with guns he's saying the
big threat to Children is guns not drag
queens no one's saying that drag queens
are murdering children we're saying that
drag queens are scandalizing children
and drag queen's Story Hour is bringing
often uh sexual criminals child
molesters into places like libraries and
schools to jiggle around in sexualized
costumes for children and that's
obviously depraved and wrong and in some
cases already is illegal and in other
cases should be illegal and we should
stop it
well what about the guns what are you
saying about that that's a completely
separate issue
and it's true that guns are the leading
cause of death among children it's very
close it's just slightly ahead of
automobile accidents so are you
suggesting that we ban automobiles too
what's your is your argument that we ban
guns and we take away the Second
Amendment we rewrite the Constitution
and we deny people's right to defend
themselves is that is that what you're
what are you saying you're not saying
any of that you're not making any kind
of argument at all you're trying to
distract and you're distracting by
yelling and screaming and wailing and
carrying on and as a rule of thumb if
your ideology causes you to wail and
scream first thing in the morning is
Billy Porter acknowledges there is
probably something wrong
with your ideology
I notice this every time I go visit
different schools
I'm going to be going to Purdue this
week
we're in that in a second but
I was just at the University of Buffalo
and the protesters come out and they
whale and they scream and they carry on
occasionally I'm able to speak to them
we actually have pretty pretty
interesting interview with with some of
the protesters at Buffalo coming out
soon stay tuned for that but when you
speak to them one-on-one and you just
try to get them to re be reasonable and
you say hey okay here's here's your
premise here's the logical conclusion of
that here's why your premise is wrong
here's my premise here's the conclusion
of that here's why that would that's
correct and more appealing and more
conducive to human flourishing
they can calm down but then sometimes
they just
they go right back to it and they start
wailing and they start screaming that's
a good if you find yourself falling down
that rabbit hole recognize there's
something wrong the people who are
correct the people who are confident in
their views don't need to wail and
scream sometimes cooler heads prevail
before we go we're able to to get to too
much on this today though there's not a
ton of breaking news on it we're waiting
to see if the Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg
indicts Donald Trump arrests el el
Donaldo and Trump seems to be leaning
into this
might be the best thing that could
happen to his campaign and it shows you
just how obscenely corrupt the political
system is in the United States that the
libs would now try to arrest the leader
of the political opposition the chief
rival to the current President Van Jones
who is a Democrat he's a lib he's on CNN
he is imploring his fellow Democrats
he's imploring the D.A he's saying hey
let's let cooler heads prevail and not
cross the Rubicon here my view about
this is uh I think that the heat is on
this D.A I think he's going to make a
very sober decision and I would not be
surprised if he doesn't step back from
the brain
so is this van Jones's prediction or is
this van Jones's advocacy
saying yo brag calm down here man this
is this is going to be an escalation of
the political war in this country that
we have we have never seen anything like
this a former president and current top
presidential candidate being arrested
for what because of totally trumped up
charges
now the libs are very angry with Van
Jones but he's obviously right
hard to go back from that because if
they do arrest Trump one it might help
Trump's campaign but two the Republicans
who are in these positions of authority
DA's Attorneys General and governors to
bring political pressure
should arrest five of their guys
not innocent people but criminal Libs
there's no shortage of criminal Libs out
there who are not being held to account
by the law
if they arrest our guy we need to arrest
five of their guys
okay and we'll see and we'll see who's
laughing by the end of that exercise
okay if the conservatives can muster the
spine I think they might be able to
conservatives have mustered a lot more
of a spine in recent years
then we can't just roll over and allow
the libs to arrest the political
opposition and turn us into a complete
Banana Republic so we have to arrest
their guys and it escalates and it
escalates and escalates and is that
where the libs want to take the
political order
maybe they're willing to take the BET
maybe they're willing to play that game
of chicken but that's a dangerous game
of chicken says van Jones and he says
back off guys
right now our political order is hanging
on by a Razor's Edge
when is a razor more than just a razor
how about when it shaves your stubble
and cuts down woke companies who hate
you all in one single stroke after years
of so-called Men's Grooming companies
waging open War on masculinity daily
wire co-ceo Jeremy boring created a
better shaving alternative it started a
year ago when we launched the inaugural
founder series raiser since then Jeremy
has been in the lab crafting a new model
behold
the Precision 5 razor
this is the latest shaving Masterpiece
from Jeremy's razors it's crafted with a
luxurious tungsten handle five welded
steel blades and a flip back trimmer for
a close smooth shave around hairlines
and hard to reach places stop giving
your money to leftist companies that
hate you
join the over one hundred thousand men
who ditched their Rogue razors and
switched to Jeremy's go to Jeremy's
razors.com
today
I'm going to Purdue I guess I'm going to
Purdue tomorrow I better finish writing
my speech I have not finished writing my
speech yet and already
multiple
protests are scheduled to try to stop my
visit
according to the Purdue exponent two
different protests have been planned
against May one will take place
at the same Ballroom that I will be
speaking in my critics are so confused
that they can't even agree on how to
protest me
and the posters the ones that I've seen
at least say that I'm a fascist they put
all sorts of swastikas on me they say no
fascists allowed on campus
you know a week ago I learned that I was
a genocidal Maniac I had never
considered myself much of a genocide man
but that's what I learned by reading the
newspapers now I learn I'm a fascist
again had not really considered myself a
fascist but maybe I'll have to go back
to some of those fascist writings try to
read I'm pretty sure I'm not a fascist
but that's what they say they just
escalated up and up and up it does go
along with my new nickname Benito
michalini uh but they'll do anything
they'll do anything to prevent me from
speaking and why why is that
it's because two weeks ago I said that
men can't really be women and we should
stop pretending that they can and we
should stop indulging this Preposterous
ideology in public life at every level
and they lost it and they were so they
were so convinced they could cancel me
and then when the entire conservative
media from the most squishy to the most
from yeah basically the most squishy I'm
not going to name names but very very
squishy media figures on the right all
the way to the most right wing they
essentially all defended my speech
because it's obviously true men can't
really be women and we can't tolerate
this stuff we really should not tolerate
it then
top Republican politicians multiple U.S
senators they came out and the libs were
so angry that they weren't able to
squash this idea
they were so angry that for the first
time in a very long time conservatives
might not just be playing defense and
trying to slow down the lips we might be
trying to reclaim ground that the libs
thought they had already conquered they
were so angry that now they're calling
me Hitler they're going to try to shut
this down they threaten violence they do
all this kind of stuff okay well doesn't
worry us
we we come in prepared you're not going
to intimidate us we'll be there on
Thursday so if you're in the Purdue area
come on by say hey and you can listen to
the speech there's a story I wanted to
get to a few days ago and I'm glad we
have at least a minute to get to it
right now
this was a story and vice
that's a kind of a science story and I
don't know anything about the science
but it did get me thinking the headline
is a growing number of scientists are
convinced the future influences the past
that the it's not just that causation
goes from
the past to the Future
but that the future can influence the
past in a way I talked to a guy who has
one of the highest IQs ever recorded and
he
suggested something similar and it kind
of I said I couldn't quite understand it
someone here says our instincts of time
and causation are our deepest strongest
instincts that physicists and
philosophers and humans are loath to
give up
but
that's what these scientists who are
quoted and vice are saying got me
thinking there's a Catholic saint a
recent Saint very very famous priest of
the 20th century named Padre Pio Padre
Pio had all these sorts of Miracles
associated with him he received the
Stigmata the wounds of Christ
miraculously he
many many miracles are attributed to
Padre Pio and there's a story about him
apocryphal or not which is that one time
he was praying and someone asked Padre
Pio who are you praying for and he said
I'm praying that my great great
grandfather will have a good death
and the person said well you're Gregor
grandfather obviously died a very long
time ago why are you praying for that
and padrepio said because God is outside
of time and space and so my prayers what
for me inside of time and space can be
efficacious because for God
time is not a problem
whether it's apocryphal or not it
tells you something true I think and
important
life has Integrity to it the creation
has Integrity to it this is something
I've noticed about all the greatest
works of art is that the the great works
of art that can really make you reduce
you to tears that can that can really
inspire you that really resonate with
the soul our works of art in which
everything fits together
and this is one of the great debates of
our time
is does the world make sense or does the
world not make sense
is the world is there Providence do
things matter do things have purpose do
things have meaning are we here for a
reason are we here at the very right
moment that God know every hair on our
head before we were born or is it all
just a kind of a cosmic accident caused
by a a random blip in the natural laws
of the universe created by who knows
whatever they're just there and one day
we're going to turn off and take a dirt
nap and turn to warm food which is it
which is I tend to believe it's the
former I don't think we could even
wonder at the question if if the world
were not intelligible if there if there
were not an underlying intelligibility
to things and so
it is the former and if it's the former
this means that one one wants to have
integrity throughout one's whole life
throughout all of creation because when
God looks at our lives he's not looking
at us Moment by Moment by moment
he's looking at the whole thing from
outside of time and space that's how you
resolve Free Will and
Providence and Grace
the fact that things happen according to
a divine order
it's the first time I've ever read any
religious Insight in Vice magazine
but it seems to be catching on it's
catching on with Tulsi gabbard it's
called catching on with New York city
mayor Eric Adams remember he said that
things really went downhill and we took
prayer out of schools
it's catching on even in Vice true
religion is resonating we've had enough
false religion true religion is
resonating
conservatives should get more
comfortable thinking about it and acting
on it and speaking in those terms the
rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member and use code Knoll
Scandal wlas a check out for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you